Hôm nay, đúng đỏ có hay bị tám hành bị bị phạm hành chính tăng bức trình phạt bằng buộc về năm
và khai lần bức trình phạt Trung, rõ chính phục vi định.
Với lính vực giáo thông đường bộ linh qua trở tử rút thì
hà nội tăng bức phạt với bỗn hành bị.
Hãy bây giờ dùng sách lấy làm quay hàng nư đậm trên đường về cảnh trở giáo thông.
Bị phạt từ hai trong vình đầu đến bốn trăng nghìn đồng.
Hãy bắn hàng giáo hoặc bắn hàng hoá nhỏ lại khách trên lòng lượng
trên về hạt khách tuyên phố của quy định cập bắn hàng.
Bị phạt từ bốn săng nghìn đồng đến năm trong nghìn đồng.
Hãy bây giờ dùng trải phép lòng đường về hài đề họp trở
kích xuân dịch vụ ăn muốn, bây bắn hàng hoá, sửa chữa tương tiệt,
máy móc, khách bị rửa xe, nật châu biển hiểu, khoảng cáo bị phạt từ bốn trường đồng đến sống trường đồng.
Hãy bí không tất thủ các quy định về dừng xe, lũa tải nơi đường bộ sống trông cùng bước vi định sách.
Dừng xe đủ xe trong phạm vi bỏ về công trình đường sách,
phạm vi ăn toàn của được sách, bị phạt từ bốn trường đồng đến hài trường đồng.